hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to road redemption a game
that was inspired by Road Rash which is
an old game that spans a lot of
generations of consoles but either way
it's about you being a motorcyclist
beating the hell out of every other
motorcyclists on the road I mean what's
not to love
ok so this game is a lot about being on
a motorcycle gathering melee weapons and
beating the ever living crap out of
everyone else around you I may have said
that already but I just blasted through
the first level without actually saying
anything else because I was kind of
having fun
so either way this is the second level
of the game and the requirement is I
need to kill 5 people or quote-unquote
defeat I know I know what I need to do I
know
please wait - I have a katana oh boy
who's gonna be fun and quick how are
they able to withstand the could Oh God
oh look at chopped his head off why
would I want to switch to a pipe from a
katana
hello mr. policeman sorry Judy oh that
was a car ok then
whoa whoa hey you want to back up a step
woah you two fightin break it up there
ok didn't mean to do that
scuse me pardon me back back back back
back back chump chop chop any chip
god dammit a rubber is that this what's
that the sound of someone dying or
someone not being okay
get out here oh thank you okay I just
killed officer friendly or defeated not
killed where huh
come on where yet okay what's going on
up there yeah
Stephens got whoa oh geez
you think this road is unsafe for normal
people I gotta kill you in ten seconds
welp I guess I'm done hey good to me
yeah these riders how dare they try to
get on with their morning commute
ah he's dead so a lot of this game at
war that guy just got eaten by that car
oh there we go
ah that's what I needed oh my god Oh
gonna dance okay we're gonna catch up
and not get blown up all right then do I
recover nitro in any way hey half block
I gotta have explosives whoa hey whoa
hey whoa this road is getting a little
crazy are you I got a present for you
come here it's really cool there you go
Hey
okay you need one of these Howie I just
tried to help you
whoa whoa I'm coming for ya I'm coming
for you gotta run awful well this is
wrong
come on just one please Oh God
what about cars can I stick them on
regular cars yeah I can
rearview mirror now how do I have that
finish first or second my mom oh oh god
okay first lesson two pipe bombs
actually drop them before you die
I throw them ahead no drop it Oh
apparently I wasted someone really I
just ran over another person what do I
care
I'm homicidal maniac to me you're
wearing the same colors as me we in a
game together our truncheon in front of
me I can hold it
ah that's how I get the guys by me Oh
God oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy
oh come on hello yeah there we go ah I
thought I got here
I still got first place oh that's good
what the hell this game is awesome this
game is really fun weapons and all that
cool stuff and I dodge that guy without
even looking that's how cool I am
did not dodge that guy I'm alive I think
pointed the wrong direction I would have
rather wiped out cuz that I could have
been placed back onto the road that
would have been nice Ted you decide to
be a douche I don't even have explosives
alright then okay then alright well
anyway this game is
Oh Nelly what is what is going on today
what is traffic decided to kill
everybody on the road oh my god how did
I survive that at least I'm in first
that's cool oh oh there was nothing I
could do nothing goes over my head my
reflexes are too quick
yes okay watch it okay very easily go
off the road kill five riders you got it
buddy oh whoops I just passed one blow
everything up I put this one on this
dude right here come on there we go
goodbye oh boy
god damn stop getting on the wrong side
of me I just want to give you a present
there we go okay bye I did yeah I did it
boom boom shine oh yeah yeah gotcha
fine oh come here you thank you you want
to everybody get to the escape point
without dying
okay well car stop
okay I thought dying men okay nevermind
I'm gonna think it all God why is this
happening
should I ask why do I wanna know ready
then or at least they bounce it gives me
a chance at life the car I was watching
the sky room alesis brinjal shelter me
from the storm nope it does not okay
so what you're trying to tell me is that
this game is not logical this game is
absolutely illogical okay what the hell
oh really dude
really dude well thank you for pointing
out the shortcut to me I guess I like
that the cloud is still following me
thank you
what is that who's that what is that
good job get it away okay thank you I
know I'm literally the best what what
finish first or second all videos all
vehicles hate me does that mean is I
tried it oh they're trying to get me
that's exactly what that means okay
excuse me
Wow alright then didn't even get a
chance to move no no no no no I'm really
a nice guy a few vehicles want to give
me a chance no
whoa hey whoa hey whoa hey whoa hey whoa
whoa no no no no no no no no no no no no
thank you
they don't exactly do a good job of
coming after me whoa Nelly
well this seemed easy this isn't nearly
as hard as they suggested it was gonna
be oh okay I'm okay
okay I'm all right oh no oh no I'm back
at the beginning of the game no all I
want you to play so much more okay so
apparently that is the majority of road
Redemption as available right now now
the game is $25 on the store's website
or it's coming out to seem pretty soon I
don't know when it's hard to justify
that price for this game because there's
not a lot here like I was having a lot
of fun there's a lot of potential for
the game but even at $25 I don't know
what else they could add because $25
does get you the final game when it does
come out but I don't know what else they
could add that would justify that high
of a price but either way it's up to you
you guys decide for yourself if you want
to play it the link to the games website
is on the description below or you can
find it in steam in a couple months
maybe it'll come out on sale when it
first launches I don't know putting
either way this was a ton of fun I got
to admit I had a great time just I only
had like 20 minutes worth a great time
though anyway thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation for more
videos that I've done and as always I
will see you in the next video bye bye
there's one final winner